[Musique]
le collège de cambuston fête ses 40 ans
et pour l'occasion
professeur invité et collégiens se sont
retrouvés au sein de l'établissement
pour marquer l'événement est ce qu'au
niveau du cadre c'est bien ça il ya
beaucoup d'activités pour vous comme
quoi par exemple le collège donc
voudrait bien sûr partager cette joie
avec les collégiens ici présents avec la
génération de 1976 avec l'équipe
éducative et avec son quartier donc je
dirais avec vous les jeunes
joyeux anniversaire une exposition
photos retracent l'évolution du site au
cours des 40 dernières années des
anciens élèves invités se sont retrouvés
pour fêter cet anniversaire
on avait des preuves plus ou moins
sévères qui nous a vraiment à un culte
et apporter de façon pérenne les bonnes
manières de la vie et qui nous sert
actuellement
et puis on peut dire que tout le groupe
qui est là aujourd'hui ce sont des
personnes qui ont pas mal réussi quand
même et on est fiers et contents de
revenir tout ça on n'a rien et nous
rappeler tout ça avec beaucoup d'émotion
l'année dernière le collège de cambuston
gagne le concours collet fleuri dans la
catégorie jardins une récompense pour
cet établissement sensible à la
protection de l'environnement
il ya eu la volonté de l'équipe
enseignante du collège d'accompagner de
répondre présent un projet de
département le plus beau cola et fleurie
ils ont eu ce prix là à un moment donné
donc je souhaite saluer cette équipe
enseignante qui a su accompagner ces
élèves là mais également le travail des
élèves qui ont été très motivés et sont
constamment ce genre de projet est
d'ailleurs quand on arrive à l'entrée du
collège on voit tout de suite cet espace
qui vient
aménagée d'un point de vue
environnemental comme 76 autres collèges
publics cambuston est prise en charge
par le département de la réunion une
compétence obligatoire dans l'accueil la
restauration et l'entretien général et
technique de ces établissements du
secondaire
[Musique]